[Applaudissements]
mes partisans du canadien vont vivre
pour une septième fois l'excitation
d'une participation en finale
d'association
une septième fois depuis la consécration
des efforts d'une équipe dirigée par un
entraîneur recrue il y à 35 ans le
canadien de jean perron se rendaient
jusqu'au bout la finale d'association la
plus récente remonte à 2014 contre les
rangers
[Musique]
une blessure subie par carey price
freine l'élan des glorieux battus en six
matches
un autre parcours mémorable celui de
2010 ce printemps halak
inspiré par son gardien le canadien des
mines des capitaux et des pingouins
avant d'être blanchi à trois reprises
par des failles et vaincus en cinq
matches
aujourd'hui montréal est de nouveau
apporté par une frénésie inattendue qui
nous rappelle celle de la coupe stanley
en 1993 le canadien avait surpris des
nordiques puis s'était offert un
balayage contre les sabres lors du 21 le
canadien renverse toronto puis d'aller
les jets
le scénario est similaire en 1993
le nouvel entraîneur jacques demers mène
son équipe à la coupe stanley et cette
chanson résonne sans s'installe
vestiaires
[Musique]
jusqu'où ira le canadien de l'entraîneur
recrue par intérim dominique ducharme et
compte en commun toutes les meilleures
performances du ch
durant ces 35 ans chaque fois le
canadien était dirigée par un nouvel
entraîneur jean françois poirier et
radio-canada mourir